a few years ago during what I thought
was a routine blood test I discovered I
had a lump on my brain thankfully a very
benign lump we like to think of
ourselves as immortal we don't want to
see the full stop my diagnosis was a
shock I felt alone and suddenly
disconnected from my body
but if we choose to explore our bodies
the possibility of hope is endless this
is the second of three films exploring
axes role in research that's changing
our lives for the better I don't know
about you but I've often grown up
thinking it's nature versus nurture like
the two were mutually exclusive concepts
but what if they're not what if you got
your genetic blueprint but could do
things in your life here and now that
made your chances of living a longer
life better I'm off to meet a guy who
unlocks the secrets of our bodies and
helps us to live better now Peter I'm
someone who running slightly contrary to
the flow is not tired of experts I love
an expert and you're the main man here
today tell me what the acts of funding
has meant for you and the work that you
do the acts of fun things been
fundamental to my research that I've
been able to look at how DNA differences
between you and I might affect how long
each of us live the AXA Research Fund is
interested in funding research about
some of the big themes in our society
things like big data things like climate
change so I put forward my proposal to
study how DNA affects lifespan and when
it comes to analyzing genetics
presumably there is no more interesting
case study than twins that's right so
twins have been the cornerstone of much
genetic research for a long long time
and what Saints are particularly
identical trends truly identical so we
see things like eye color whether your
hair is curly then a lot of the more
interesting traits are not necessarily
identical to them and for me things like
two identical twins will often not
suffer from the same diseases the law
was certainly not live exactly the same
amount of time I'm Ross I'm Hugo and
we're the Tanner twins we go off on
expeditions all over the world and as
we're twins it allows medical research
teams to study how our bodies are
affected in extreme environments
individually we're not that interesting
but I guess as a huge research study and
you build without it then suddenly
starts becoming an incredibly valuable
data set so it's a really really
exciting to kind of be part of some
pioneering research as twins that we can
kind of go off and do our expeditions
and come at it from a slightly different
angle I mean my dad has an identical
twin and
he went on to develop three primary
cancers over 20 years and my and
possibly two years ago and my uncle
still alive and thriving and has never
ever been been touched with it with a
day of cancer I don't think a lot of
people know actually how much research
time effort professionalism you know the
greatest minds in the world are actually
working on problems that we might not
appreciate now but in 10 20 years time
the advances in medical research and
understanding and the techniques that
are able to treat such conditions will
be so so far beyond what they are today
you've given good data for that we thank
you god I am for you look at you how
much would you say our lives are
dependent on our genes and how much it's
predicated on things like lifestyle
healthy eating exercise all that sort of
stuff about a sixth of how long we live
for example is under direct genetic
control the rest of it's about
environment and in fact the interaction
between those two things I'm actually
surprised by what a small number that is
actually because sometimes you feel like
you're under the cosh of your own
heredity you know you sort of feel that
oh I'm born with this sort of genetic
sequencing that's absolutely going to
dictate but you're saying that really we
have so much free will in terms of how
we navigate our health and well-being
absolutely you and I both have about
three billion letters in this huge
genome that we keep hearing about and
what I'm trying to do is understand how
individual pieces of that genome affect
how long we live for me it's it's not
just how long we live but it's how well
we live I think that it's more
fundamental and I think by understanding
the aging process and understanding
susceptibility to disease it's very much
my hope that as we live longer we live
healthier and happier as well when I was
diagnosed things changed suddenly my
insides felt alien like they were
working against me I was stunned by how
little control I felt I had over my own
body blood net today were already much
further along the journey
understanding ourselves and people
thought possible genetic research being
supported by the AXA Research Fund means
we can comprehend our specific needs and
to nourish them like all the great
moments in human experience this is
possible because of collaboration
scientists volunteers and those willing
to adventure have combined to unlock the
deepest mysteries within all of us
[Music]